the power is back on at Disneyland this
morning after sections of the park went
dark during one of its busiest weeks of
the year a late morning transformer
failure hit the theme park in Anaheim
California just south of Los Angeles
Jamie yuccas talked to some of the
guests who have their trips cut short by
the outage the power failure made the
fun at Disneyland grind to a halt
Wednesday there are a lot of crying
children and unhappy guests
you can't get on rides you can't buy
things in stores they had little
reservations to get made over like
princesses they can't they can't do it
they can't even get their computers up
and running the magic of Disney sort of
fades a little bit when the power's out
in half the park
about a dozen rides were affected some
fans came in from Oklahoma and Georgia
for Rose Bowl team events we left the
park cause it's way too busy and it's
probably gonna get worse in from Texas
Corolla Crespo said she and her friend
Alessandra did not have a carefree time
we were on a ride when we found out
there is no powder outage so we were
just praying that it wouldn't hit us
right when we were on the top of the
ferris wheel guests took to social media
to vent their frustration Disneyland
said it escorted guests off the affected
attractions shortly after the outage a
park spokesperson told CBS News an issue
with a transformer resulted in loss of
power to toontown and Fantasyland we
sincerely apologize for the
inconvenience to all of our guests the
Taylors for Melbourne Australia paid big
bucks to troll the park with their
four-year-old daughter grace how much
did you pay to go to the park well you
know fifteen hundred dollars yet so to
take a day chunk out it's a big deal for
CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles a lot of money
to go there Disneyland tickets usually
are only refundable if they are unused
power was restored to the entire park
within a few hours
Australian still couldn't strive though
I mean people wait years to go there
they plan a trip for a year amazing I
wouldn't want to be stuck on one of
those rides I'm afraid of them to begin
with so
no one would want to be second one this
Reitsma hydra with you